mientras el mundo se enfoca en combatir
el cob y 19 otras enfermedades
infecciosas siguen cobrándose cientos de
miles de vidas en todo el mundo la
tuberculosis sigue siendo la enfermedad
infecciosa más mortal del mundo tan sólo
el año pasado dejó un millón y medio de
muertes mientras se extiende
mundialmente junto al vih y la malaria
parece que la lucha contra estas
enfermedades está mermando por primera
vez en 20 años
tantas vidas
so much as travesas a managers tanto
esfuerzo durante tantos años y podríamos
ver como todo eso se revierte no podemos
dejar que eso ocurra las uy uy uy uy
descalabrar aja el fondo mundial es un
consorcio de gobiernos y grupos del
sector privado que donan miles de
millones de dólares para luchar contra
las enfermedades infecciosas cada año
según la asociación en 2020 el número de
personas tratadas por tuberculosis
resistente a los medicamentos se redujo
en un 19% las pruebas de detección del
vih cayeron en un 22% y las personas
sometidas a pruebas de detección de
malaria bajaron un 4% con el dinero
fluyendo hacia la lucha contra el cubit
el fondo mundial afirma que los
resultados no están muy lejos de ser
catastróficos ya que han costado cientos
de miles de vidas no obstante su informe
contiene algunos destellos de esperanza
los pacientes que recibieron terapia
antirretroviral de por vida contra el
vih aumentaron en un 9% y las medidas de
prevención contra la malaria se
mantuvieron estables en comparación con